I think a fantastic Sunday roast is the
cornerstone of home cooking is what the
rest of the week meals are built around
and I absolutely love it but that
doesn't mean it can't be improved to
make the most out of my roast my main
course is the village of stuff roast rib
of beef complete with tangy horseradish
Yorkshire puddings vas is the rib eye
we've had that in the fridge not wrapped
so it's sort of almost air dries and it
intensifies the flavor roast so much
quicker and there's less water in the
beef for me the only downside of perfect
roast dinner is the fight about who
washes up afterwards
so meg and I are going to avoid that by
cooking everything in one rossington
starting with a spinach and mushroom
stuffing so with a salt and pepper
please
thank you
and with the garlic and the mushrooms
toss the pan you push down and pull back
down and push back off you go take your
time
sit down don't leave that good that's it
push down
nice that was lovely and again nice
although more than one right we're sort
of making it well you'll touch your
butter in the middle now we just start
putting the spillage in the middle piece
so you can push that down suppose just
cold so you're not gonna burn yourself
be confident in the pan toss it and
you'll see it wilting and disintegrating
away who'd have thought all that spinach
could fit in this pan because it's a
very delicate leaf it sort of cooks so
quickly put this all on your board now
and then I just want you to get a nice
chop then when you're confident with one
hands wait to pick up the other line for
the other head drop it nicely yes now
outside and come in gently yes
mmm I love that so why is that lemon
thyme lemon times faster you get your
little time stalks
and you pull down sort of strip lemon
thyme in now tagging no taste brilliant
with the beef fantastic with chicken and
fish roughly chopped the target and I
sprinkling the fresh breadcrumbs so the
breadcrumbs almost sort of bring the
stuffing together mm-hmm next we're
gonna get an egg yolk now with a beef
this is exciting car slice with the bone
and then come inside and go two-thirds
of the way down
Oh
salt and pepper and then look we pack
our stuffing in there this amazing it's
incredible now just gently hold that
there like that okay yep
I'll see you tomorrow what tying string
around the rib will keep it all together
during roasting not too tight if you're
tight too tightly what happens yes
nothing will come out that's right
that's ready for roasting but I'm gonna
protect it and fit it on a trivet so
trivet basically it's almost like a sort
of little bed little bears that's right
if you want to enjoy these delicious
roast vegetables at their best make sure
you remove them from the hot oven after
35 minutes and reheat before serving
with your beef now a little mix for the
top I took a teaspoons of mustard powder
in salt a couple of tablespoons of olive
oil mix that in and a pour my mustard
powder over the beef so this forms a
really nice glaze my one pot roast
dinner goes into a hot oven 15 minutes
at 230 degrees then down to 170 degrees
for another two hours each
fried delicious twist on traditional
Yorkshire puts on the lace mine with
fresh horseradish
start with plain white flour in a bowl
and cracking the eggs adding only half
of your milk at this stage makes it much
easier to whisk all the lumps out and if
like me you like your puddings a little
lighter and crispier add a dribble of
cold water and add salt to season when
you're happy your batter is lump free
whisk in the remaining milk peel and
grate horseradish and add a handful to
the mix we can leave the batter to rest
while we get the meat from the oven but
is beautiful and this is where you
really need to let it rest I like to
rest the meat for at least 20 minutes
it's just the right amount of time for
us to wake up the oven and to get our
Yorkshire puddings in I love using the
rich dripping but best of all it's a
healthier option to get the fluffiest
Yorkshire your tray and fat must be
piping hot for best results take your
jug of batter to the oven and pour the
mixture in there it takes just 15
minutes for our Yorkshire PUD to puff
themselves up and turn a delicious
golden brown lift that up place that
onto the board
Pasteur's parents you can see why we
kept them in half
they've got all that flavor one
beautiful big slice for daddy
one for Mickey and then the side it's
stopping there's nothing a bit that's to
die for no fantastic your chips they're
amazing aren't they beautiful
that's be my darling
beautiful roast beef with a twist
Wow with the younger kids out of friends
it's down to just me
taarna and Megan to get stuck in that is
a rib eye fit for a king who's cooked
deeply thank you thank you
explain to mom losing the stuff and
placed on the stuffing has mushrooms
lemon thyme tarragon and spinach
favorite part
what's your job I really enjoy doing the
stuffing it's not as hard as it looks
Bon Appetit everyone